as functional programmers we figured out
a better way to do data transformation
no longer do we do these manual for
loops where we have to think about I and
J and temp and all of these variables
that are constantly changing their
values over time no longer are we trying
to look at these nested for-loops
to try to figure out what in the world
our code is doing instead we have this
clean way we have these functions like
filter MapReduce partition zip with we
have a clean clear way of doing data
transformation and so if we've really
made something better we have to ask him
what way is it better like what have we
gained and these are the sorts of things
that we talk about we have more readable
code right and so maybe some of you're
saying like no it's not more readable
I've read people's functional code and
it's an atrocious it's ugly but like
sometimes you know when we first see it
it is hard to read but after we've
learned these things there's these
patterns that we've been trying to say
in our for loops there are these
patterns that we've been wanting to talk
about and now we've given it a name it's
Matt it's filter it's partition and
throw in a lot of ways it is more
readable we also have this declarative
approach when I say map
I don't have to think about how the map
is going on it could be lazy it could be
strict it could be doing it in parallel
we could have intermediate data
structures or we could have
deforestation our compiler can be smart
about this because we're not telling the
computer step by step what to do we're
saying what we want and so we get to
focus on the what and not the how or at
least this is what we tell ourselves we
tell ourselves we've really come up with
this better way but today I want to
question like is it that much better
right have we really made a better
approach to data transformation let's
look at some code to like just some fake
code to think about this so here I have
the stereotypical pipeline right maybe
you're not a pipeline person maybe you
think pipelines are overrated but think
about your ideal functional code that
does j2 transformation think about it in
your header look at this one on the
slide and ask
some questions about it like what are
the shape of my input by looking at this
we really can't tell what's the shape of
my output something something about foo
and bar we have no way of knowing and
some of you right now cuz I'm at Strange
Loop we're thinking yeah that's cuz
you're using closure if you use if you
use Haskell like you should you would
know the types right you know the type
of the input you know the type of the
output and you know the types all the
way down and that's that's true like
types are great I'm not here to talk bad
about types but that's not what I'm
talking about
right when we look at our code if we've
told ourselves we have a declarative
approach then shouldn't our code reflect
the problem that we're solving shouldn't
our code reflect the problem that we're
solving and it doesn't it doesn't look
like it in the end if there's a bug in
this code I have to think about step by
step how this code is accomplishing it
and I have to think where could that a
value come in this pipeline and this
isn't simple pipeline like maybe it's
actually nested and maybe if you wrote
it you can figure it out but if your
coworker did there's no way you're
figuring that out in the end we still
end up playing computer in our head we
are still thinking about step by step
how the computer is accomplishing our
tasks and so that's what we're gonna
start with today we're gonna be talking
about meander which is the closure
library made for doing declarative data
transformation and we're going to talk
about me enter and its philosophy how it
views programming how it views
programming as data transformation then
in this section we're going to be
looking at some practical examples of
like realistic data transformation they
have to sit on my slides so they're not
gonna be the things that you actually do
it work but you know they're gonna be
analogs then we're gonna talk about how
could we take this approach how we can
take this approach further with meander
you know I'm gonna show these like kind
of silly little problems that you might
think well yeah but my problem it's more
complicated than that and I have a forty
minute talk to try to show you all of
the things on the inner can do no I
can't do that so we're just gonna
just look at like look there's more
features than what I can show you in 40
minutes
then finally we're gonna look at the
future and we're gonna look at me and
errs near-term future the things that we
have planned for it the way that we can
extend it but we're also gonna look at
the distant future what if we took the
idea of coding is just data
transformation seriously
what have we extended this philosophy
that meander as a library has had to an
actual programming language what
features will we get what benefits where
we have maybe we could actually have a
declarative language that can do the
things that we want to do so before we
dive into all that just a little bit of
introduction my name is Jimmy I work for
ads irk we provide an API that lets you
build an ad server to do server-side
sorry a server-side ad platform we're
hiring
we're also sponsors of Strange Loop so
if you're interested come talk to me we
have a booth find people who work in ads
Eric reach out so meander meandered this
closure library it actually got accepted
into closures together which is a great
nonprofit that you know raising money
for people to support open source
software and it's being actively worked
on but one thing I really want to call
out here is that it borrows heavily from
this concept called term rewriting so
we're really indebted to these great
languages like Stratego mod pure or
maybe one that you might have heard of
like Mathematica that have like
pioneered this idea of term rewriting
and applied in a lot of ways and we've
taken a lot of inspiration from them I
wanted to talk about this in my talk but
there just isn't time so I really would
just want to you know say there's some
prior art here but we've taken this and
moved it to more practical I don't want
to say practical more everyday things
things that were I'm doing on my in my
day job that you're probably doing in
your day job but I want to say for sure
that I am NOT the creator of meander
this man here who I know is falcon so
that's what I'm gonna call him Falcon is
the creator of meander Falcon is a
fantastic software engineer that I had
the pleasure of working with who's
worked tirelessly on meander who is
really thinks about how we should relate
to our code and what our
code should look like so I'm greatly
indebted to Falcon who unfortunately
couldn't make it to Strange Loop this
year so let's dive in let's start with
the hello world problem here's our hello
world problem statement on the Left we
have input on the right we have output
this is really really simple and right
now you're probably thinking how you
would write this code in your language
and it would be great code because it's
a hello world problem every language
should be able to do this easily right
so we're going to talk about how we
approach this sort of problem with
meander meander is fundamentally about
pattern matching so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take our data and we're
gonna replace some things with variables
so here I've just taken our input and
replaced all the bits I care about with
a variable so our variables here that
start with a question mark are called
logic variables and they're just gonna
match on whatever value they find and
then we can propagate these over to our
output and so now we have input an
output we have our variables matched up
and if I turn this just vertically and
wrap it in this function called match we
have the meander solution to this
problem now this isn't very exciting
this is the hello world example and your
language the code wouldn't look that
different and in fact because you're at
Strange Loop you're like did I choose
the wrong talk
is this really a talk about pattern
matching like I know what pattern
matching is I don't need to talk about
pattern matching in I'm sorry to say
like yes this is a talk about pattern
matching but it's it's better matching
on steroids it asks the question like
what if pattern matching were the
fundamental unit another way of thinking
about it is I am a closure developer so
like I really enjoy the rich data
literals that closure has I think it
lets me talk about data directly what if
I had data transformation literals what
if I could directly talk about how data
is transforming from data to data how
it's relating to itself and that's what
me enters about so to understand that
we're gonna go through a little bit of
an extended example alright and just
give a little background we have like I
have to come up with you know a good
relatable example so I just fix like an
RPG we have some game right like
Pathfinder D&D whatever RPG you want and
we're gonna have some players they're
gonna have weapons and we're gonna look
at like how we can take this data
structure we're start with the data
structure definition we'll look at it
what we want to do to this data
structure and we'll look at the meander
code for doing it and we'll see some of
the power that underlies this stuff so
here's our data structure in its
entirety but this is like a lot of text
on the slide so we're gonna break it
down right so so here's what we have we
have four parts that we really care
about we have our players we have our
weapons we have the stats these are the
stats of the weapons and we have a set
of third-party weapons all right so
here's our look here's our players right
so we have three players we have Jim ER
we have sir we'll and we have dal Gris
we have a class each player has a
classroom we have warrior Knight and
rogue alright pretty simple pretty basic
players could have had a lot more but
you know this is a toxin so here we have
our weapons so we have the name of the
weapon and then we have the allowed
classes for any of you who aren't
closures this hash curly brace is a set
we have a set of values here so we have
a warrior and a knight and it allowed
classes are you know if you the only
people who can use this weapon right so
these are the classes that can use this
weapon and then we also have the
standard upgrade every weapon will have
a standard upgrade and
seeing stats that we have more upgrades
okay so here's our stats our stats are
just a map from weapon name to their
stats you know you're almost never
wanting to just like loop over stats and
just list that you want to look up stats
so here's our stats and you'll see here
that a weapons can have this additional
upgrade and they also have an attack
power and then finally the last part of
our data definition is this third-party
weapons we have the unbeatable weapon as
third-party weapons always seem to be so
here is our requirements right we want
to find all the valid player weapon
combinations okay so they're disallowed
classes and each player has a class and
we need to make sure that these things
match up right we're gonna find all the
valid player weapon combinations we need
the name once we do that we need the
name of the player the name of the
weapon the class of the player the
attack power and all the upgrades that's
the standard upgrades and those that are
in stats and right now well actually
let's look at the output first so here's
the output given our dataset this is
what we should get you can see see here
Jimmer has two different weapons that he
could use the long sword in the short
sword where's the other two you only
have one and you can see we gathered up
all those upgrades right now right now
your programmer you're thinking okay I
know how to do this and you would
probably be thinking about some apps and
filters and whatever right and you have
to think okay do I start with the
players and and look for all the weapons
do I start with the weapons and look for
all the players how do I first filter
out the third-party weapons and you can
do it it's not hard and in fact I wrote
the code enclosure here's my closure
code it's really bad code because I
intentionally made as many anonymous
functions as I could so that it wouldn't
take longer on the slide and you would
think I was cheating but there's there's
nothing I just don't like about this the
outputs actually not too bad you can
kind of see it and I've done some
unnecessary destructuring here that I
really didn't need to do but I kind of
like this be able to see what key is I'm
gonna be caring about but ultimately if
you didn't write this it is not
immediately apparent
what is our input what is our output
what does it look like and I want you to
contrast this with the meander code and
here it is so you don't know me and ER
very well
but immediately you can start seeing our
input and output we care about the
players we're here about the weapons we
hear about the stats in third party and
then ultimately we're gonna get our name
weapon class attack power and upgrades
and so this already even if you don't
know it you can start to seeing what the
data looks like and so I want to talk of
I want to walk through this and tell you
how this is working or at least explain
what's going on here so we start with
search so search is in the and our
function that allows us to get multiple
answers out so we're giving it a pattern
to match on and it's going to find all
instances of our pattern that match so
here we have players and we're gonna say
we have our game info that's that big
data structure we have players I'm going
to say we're gonna scan the players
all right so scan just says given a
collection find anything that matches
this pattern okay so we're gonna find
them bath that has a name in a class and
we're gonna assign question mark name in
question mark class we're gonna do the
exact same thing for our weapons we're
gonna scan through our weapons and we're
gonna have the name of the weapon we're
gonna say that's question mark weapon
and then we're gonna go to these allowed
classes and this is where it gets
interesting we have this hash this set
question mark class where we've already
defined question mark class above and so
what we're doing here is we're joining
across these data structures we're
saying whatever you found in the players
whatever class it was better be in the
set of allowed classes so now we can do
this joint and then we have underneath
that the standard upgrade and we have
this new variable type called a memory
variable and it says bang upgrades and
what memory variables do is they
remember anything that they match on so
they get added to a list of values okay
we can move on now we can go nurse stats
well look our stats is a lookup so we
have this weapon what we've already
defined weapon up above so again we're
joining across these and we're doing a
constant time lookup through this
drawing then we have the attack power
and we're saving that off and then we
have our upgrades and here that's memory
variable comes in to real play we say
bang up we say I'm looking for a vector
a list of things right and I
banging upgrades it's gonna match and
then this dot dot means repeat zero more
times basically find all the things that
are in here and just save them all off I
want to keep them all and then finally
we get to third-party and we just say
and it better not match the pattern that
our weapon is in the set of third-party
weapons and this is weird this is a very
different approach and right now you
have a lot of skepticism about like why
like no this isn't better I like my map
filter Noriega's and like that's okay or
maybe like this is gonna be too slow all
right like probably that's where you
think and we'll talk about that but I
think this really gets at the data
transformation that we've been trying to
do we have our output now very directly
we have a way of doing this and I found
when I went to write this code all I did
was copy and paste my data structures
and change little bits it became really
obvious I didn't have to think do I
start with the weapons do I start with
the thing I just thought about my data
and described the relationships between
it and what I found is when I reach
factored this code it also becomes
really obvious if for example let's say
I have some bad data and sometimes the
players name is nil and when it is like
it's just bad I don't want it I just put
in or not nil up at that name I don't
have to add another filter and figure
out where it should go in the pipeline I
don't have to restructure my code in any
way to change my input and output but of
course you know this is just one example
let's look at some other ones so here's
uh I grab down a random JSON file from a
game called pixelmon so it's actually a
mod for Minecraft to let you play
pokemon in Minecraft and they have this
like ridiculous JSON file that has item
templates and there's all the possible
items in the game and some of those
items are Pokemon but the way they do
them is they just have Pokemon settings
until what this actually does is I pull
out all the rare Pokemon so if they have
a rarity this is just their data
structure if they have a rarity it's
some value it's some string if they
don't it's null right and so I pull out
all the rare Pokemon I pull out their
Pokemon ID which is actually just their
name and then I pull out their forms
only certain forms I pull up their stats
and then here
I'm using another feature of me and are
called substitute where I can say I'm
remembering all of these and then I can
say hey make up me a list of all of
these for every single time you see a
Pokemon one Pokemon one form one rarity
one stats keep doing that over and over
again make these maps and so I just took
an arbitrary data structure and now I
can very declaratively say give me all
the rare Pokemon and maybe I only want
the rare Pokemon who are at their final
evolution there's things and that
there's all sort of other data in here
that I just ignored but I could add
these and they become really obvious how
to add them or maybe one a little bit
more programmatic example not Pokemon so
here meander actually works enclosure
script as well as closure so I pulled in
a JSON library or a JavaScript library
that lets me parsh JavaScript and I can
actually start doing things on the ast
so here you know JavaScript
I love JavaScript but come on like
there's like three at least three ways
or like four ways to define a function
right and so this one actually goes and
finds all my functions no matter how
nested they are no matter how many iffy
they're wrapped in or whatever right
it's like all my named functions and
finds what line number and character
they're at and so this could be function
name parentheses or it could be var or
let or Const name equals and then an
arrow function or a regular function I'm
going and mapping on the ast and so I'm
finding every single function and their
location their name and their location
and if you look at the SD this is just
the data structure that they define for
the ast I didn't have to think about how
do i recurse through the tree I didn't
have to think about any of this stuff
becomes directly obvious and then I
pulled out another one so here's ready
so if you go to reddit.com slash dot
JSON at least on old reddit I haven't I
don't use new reddit on old reddit you
can go to that I don't know if it works
on your reddit and they'll give you this
like crazy data structure of all the all
the things that are on that page right
so this is pulling down all the posts
that have an image and then it's
outputting HTML so we just get a big
HTML page of all the posts that have
images their link their title and their
source image so there's a few things
that I could call out so like you know
this is there
structure so it's a little weird they
just have this like list of images and
then the first one it's it's always the
first one has source and then I'm saying
this ampersand underscore just means
like and all that rest the rest of that
stuff ignore it I don't care about that
whatever else is in there and then here
at the bottom I'm using substitute again
and to be able to make this do this
repeat operator and what this dot dot
dot will do it says repeat all the way
up until you find a dot so the dots
where I stop I have this out outward
container and then I have all the things
elements inside of it and there's a lot
more that you can do with all of this in
fact we have a ton of operators that I
can't talk about and you know I
mentioned some of these here but you can
also define your own custom operators in
fact most of these are not primitive
operators they're defined in terms of
our more primitive operators and we dog
food our own extension method but you
maybe you have a way that you want to
talk about your data you want to
declarative approach doing this and you
can write your own operators just by
defining your own matches and then use
them you can package them up as the
library there's nothing special about
these operators you can do the same
exact things they can use arbitrary
closure coding and make this work but
still as much as these examples have
been interesting like there's a lot of
things that I can't do with what you've
shown me so far right like come on like
maybe I have a recursive data structure
where's your God now right so we can do
that right we can do some recursive data
structures so you know there's actually
a couple ways and I can only just touch
on this we don't have a lot of time to
get into how all this works and what the
trade-offs are there's there's
trade-offs here but let's just look at
one really simplistic example right so
here we have a little bit of a little
bit of code going on but you know we're
getting rid of all the zeros in addition
okay so you know if you have anything
plus zero or zero plus anything it's
just that thing so here I just defined a
pattern match this rewrite that says if
it's X plus zero then just it's X if
it's zero plus exponents X and what I'm
doing now is I'm using strategies so
when you define a rewrite rule you can
say like hey I'm actually gonna have
this like tree of things and I want you
to have a strategy for how you tackle
doing this rewrite
recursively through the tree right so
here what I'm doing is I'm saying this
first attempt strategy attempt says try
to do the pattern match and if you fail
just return me back what you had
originally right so maybe it's just two
plus three
well that doesn't match either of our
patterns so we just return back two plus
three or maybe and then we have bottom
up so bottom up says if you give me a
tree structure start at the look the
smallest element and then work your way
up right and then finally I have this
until equals which I didn't actually
need I'm pretty sure but I didn't write
a proof for it so maybe I did so I have
this until equals which just says keep
doing this thing until nothing changes
right until the old value equals the new
value and so here you can see that we
can simplify this addition but some of
you are like that's cheating all you did
was make function combinators that's not
a declarative approach to anything I can
write function Combinator's so we
actually have some ways of doing this
without cheating and going out to the
closure world we actually have a way of
talking about recursive pattern matching
and right now it's a little limited and
and this example is actually more of her
books than it needs to be because the
less verbose one is more mine bhindi so
I made it more verbose but here's here's
an example where we can actually do this
very similar thing technically these
world we produce different results and
different things anyways it's basically
the same so here we have this width
operator and with actually allows us to
do recursive pattern matching and right
now it's a little limited because you
can't pass it parameters and I'm not
going to explain exactly how this code
works because I have no idea I wrote it
and like there's there's a lot going on
but it's really cool and we can actually
have done things like you know actually
practical not just removing zeros like
write a hiccup parser that produces HTML
using this sort of thing and like the
performance isn't quite there but it's
getting there and so you know in fact up
that's what we're gonna talk about next
like everyone's thinking isn't this
going to be slow like yeah it's cool you
you've done some stuff but no one does
this for a good reason this is slow like
I've used Prolog once
it just it's just like stop like I did
something and then it just sat there in
an infinite loop forever and that's all
you're talking about like we've been
down this territory there's a reason we
don't do it and so you know let's talk
about that first off this is not
prologue and it is deterministic you're
not gonna sit there forever but like
give me a tour fast we'll Manders often
slower than the code I'm gonna write by
hand it's just just reality some of that
is because we're a little bit more
strict than closure is so if you say you
want to map we're gonna check that it's
a map before we do something and not
just like do it and blow up right where
say like is it a map oh it's not we
don't match so some of that is just like
predicate overhead but oftentimes you
know we're kind of bad at generating
code that's fast but I've never
personally had it be too slow for the
sort of problem I'm solving and if I
have maybe once I've I've gone and
changed the line of code in our compiler
and it makes it a lot better but it's
gonna continue to get faster because we
haven't been focused on this we've been
focusing on the problems that you want
to solve we've been focusing on the data
that you care about and giving you a way
to talk about it directly a way that
kind of looks like how you can talk
about on the whiteboard we want it to be
clear with going on
I can send me under code to somebody
else who doesn't know my problem and
they should be able to understand what's
going on because they can see the data
structure so that's what we've been
focused on and in order to accomplish
all this with that she mostly Falcon but
a little bit me have one in a lot of
work right under the hood we got a lot
going on we got a parser we got an
expander so those custom operators that
you can make you know they're kind of
like a little expect macro expansion
setup we have this matrix based ir which
you've ever looked at pattern matching
that's a pretty common way of doing it
we're not using it as well as we could
we have a second-level ir that's
intermediate representation so that
that's a little closer to like the code
that we put out at the end this one
actually will probably change pretty
soon we do some dead code elimination so
by default if we can tell that like
actually no we didn't need to do that
we'll get rid of a lot of the code we do
some optimization so we handle some
in cases like literals versus like
actually having to look at stuff and
then we do some simple type inference I
wrote it it's not actually type
inference but it kind of is and it helps
us with dead code elimination because
like if you pass me a map and I'm and
you have another pattern that's about
vectors well I know it's not a vector I
just get rid of that code if you only I
can actually just like only generate
code that says nope you're wrong um so
that's fun and then we have code
generation right and so we have all the
mechanism underlying everything that
lets us optimize that lets us be a lot
more efficient and you know we found
over it in our own little language kind
of you know Lisp curse thing right it's
fun though alright so what about the New
Year term future so right now our error
messages suck if your pattern doesn't
match we say your pattern doesn't match
which is true but we have all sorts of
data like in our ast is that we keep
like where you what you had the original
form even if you expand out we know the
original form not just your expanded
version we can do a lot better and it's
really just like propagating some things
I'm hoping that we can get like Elm
style error messages at some point I
think we can I think it's doable um
we're gonna make faster code right like
right now we have a lot of things that
we know are just bad like I took
something from polynomial time to
constant time like you know we have
things like that where it's like no we
just don't need to be doing that there's
no reason we were we're trying to be
guaranteed that we're gonna give you
back the result right now instead of
focusing on speed and and now we're
moving towards caring about this speed
we want to have less code generated so
if you if you're in the closure
community you have you ever used core
match you'll if you do the wrong match
you might get this code is too big for
the JVM message I've never done that
with me and ER I'm sure someone can go
out there and do it right now but I've
never accidentally done that I'm gonna
have more powerful recursive matches so
with right now is a really interesting
construct but it can't take parameters
and if it could we could do some really
cool stuff so we're gonna be doing that
and then update in place by this I don't
mean mutation
but again if you're in the closure
community Spectre might come to mind
when you're thinking about this and it's
all about like I can find some super
nested thing and like increment a number
Neander is not aimed at that right now
we don't really have a great way of
doing that we think that most of our
data transformation is actually from
this structure to a totally different or
a fairly different structure and the
only reason we're updating things where
we find them is because it's easier with
our tolling we actually could just do
the transformation as part of that step
but there are reduced cases for this and
we want to add support for it and we can
and then finally just more user
extensibility anything that we can add
you should be able to add there's no
reason that it I mean yeah there's some
core primitives but ultimately you
should be able to make things faster you
should be able to have more extensions
you should be able to add more operators
whatever you want we want you to be able
to add it yourself and I could just in
the talk here and just say like this is
me and or go use it yeah but I want to
talk about the distant future I am up
high in the sky kind of person I don't
really care about practicality that much
I care about interesting beautiful code
and so like let's talk about like where
this can go all right where can this go
so this is what I'm gonna say I think we
could actually have truly data oriented
programming if we took this seriously
term rewriting is kind of this
inspiration that we based the stuff on
it's kind of the semantics of how me and
ER is working under the hood and if we
accepted that we could have truly data
oriented programming in a way that us
Lisp programmers like to claim we
already do all right so like but we
don't and in fact we can see this like
at least in closure and you know I think
most lists have this thing let's say you
have a function a lambda and you
evaluate it what do you get back you get
back this opaque token yeah you can wrap
it in a function you could pass it to a
function you have higher-order functions
you can put it in a data structure but
can you look inside the function and see
what's going on and this might seem like
an arbitrary distinction but if you've
used libraries like core async this like
really has real ramifications where we
can't pass that lambda boundary but I
think it's more than
just this if we just solve this problem
that wouldn't be that interesting when
we talk about code is data data is code
what do we mean we mean the text of our
code looks like our data I can read it
from the reader and I get back data
structures in my language is that really
all that there is the code is that
really all that we care about I wonder
about execution as data what if the
execution of my program itself were data
well then I could do all sorts of
interesting things maybe I have a rule
that is a certain that's matching on a
certain pattern and I know what it's
called it's called my rule and it has
some variables you know it's been paying
past some arguments but for some reason
it's getting me weird results and I have
no idea what the hell arguments this
thing is being passed right and you
might be thinking well it's not that
hard to go find your function yeah
unless it's deeply nested in some node
module but I have no idea where it is
and I have to like dive down there for
like an hour looking for it because it's
dynamically generated I'm not mad um so
anyways maybe I just want to say like
hey program when you're executing things
if you see an expression called with my
rule and two arguments just print those
arguments for me why can't I do that
this is a hint if my program if my the
execution is data I can pattern match on
my execution and get out things that I
want or maybe you want to go the other
way around like I have some weird data
and I have no idea where this where your
data is coming from
please program as you're executing if
you see an expression and it results in
some weird data tell me what what's
causing this just print it out for me or
maybe we have some error message so
every time I write a division in my
program I am just counting down until
that division by zero comes up right
it's the one division in my program and
so boom division by zero on that line
yes it's my one division and then it's
like oh it's five divided by zero gave
you some more information thank you um
so like this here I've made a custom
thing which I actually could have said
on this slide it's not that hard but it
would have been like everyone staring
and squinting at lots of dots but here I
made my own cousin
vertical doll steps between and what I'm
doing is I'm saying find me in my
execution history because I can just
shave off its data I can save it right
the first instance of zero and then all
the steps in between until I have a
division by zero and return me back
those steps so now I can see like how
did I get from one place to another and
I could have added like Aaron eight
steps before that because maybe that's
more important but we can talk about the
execution history or maybe we can do
even more like what if we can have
scoped rules so there was a talk
exchanged of a camera which year but it
was about idealized commit logs using
code slicing that I thought was a really
interesting talk and the idea is if you
take a test what if I could just find
out all the code that was run just from
that one test I could understand every
single part but that test is exercising
very easily well here we could say that
right we could say with execution rule
anytime you find any role just save it
for me and now I'll run my test and I'll
see all the rules that were invoked from
that test but this is not enough right
if we have real data oriented
programming we need rules as data or
rules themselves should be data so we
can do things like this we could say hey
find me all the rules that contain print
any rule that prints I just want to know
what it is right or maybe here we say
hey I want to find all my deprecated
rules I know there's some deprecated
rule I just want to find everywhere
where it is and you have it in memory I
can just find all of these rules because
my rules themselves are data right
they're not just random text blobs in a
file
they're data or maybe we want to find
the deprecated rule and we want to
actually replace it we want to say hey
every call to my deprecated rule that
has these certain arguments replace it
with my new rule and change the order of
the arguments well finally maybe we want
to look at our rule history maybe the
language itself knows about these rules
and how they've changed over time and we
know that if code constantly is changing
that's probably where some bugs are and
we can say find me any rule that's
repeated ten or more times
and like I said I'm a pie in the sky
kind of person and this is really cool
and I've made some little
proof-of-concept here there nothing that
I would actually show anybody because
it's ugly but you know maybe you're like
okay yeah that that's cool but what
about something more immediate more real
something you actually have some working
code for right and I want to show one
more example that like we get out of
this sort of model and that's
programming by example so if you've seen
will birds barliman it's this system
that lets you write your unit tests and
then it figures out the code for you and
it does it by really cool stuff with
mini can or and writing a scheme
interpreter in scheme and you know this
big nice tower of interpreters going on
and it's really interesting because you
just write the test cases and you get
out working code but it takes quite a
while and if you mess up your test cases
as I did during a live talk it can never
return
well that's because trying to infer
functional code is hard there's a lot of
moving parts going on there's a lot of
weird things but what about trying to
infer declarative code so I've written
one that doesn't handle everything but
hails that first example the hello world
example that we talked about and it's
not in the and or proper but I have it
and it really does work and it's called
in for a rewrite and you can hand it a
single example of your input and your
output and it will give you back the
exact code that we wrote before and this
is what we can get from a declarative
data model right no yes
I haven't done repeats I haven't done
all sorts of things but when we have a
declarative data model where there's
relationships between our code and
that's all our code looks like this
becomes deterministic this becomes easy
there's these algorithms called anti
unification that are trying that they're
opposite of unification which is what
pattern matching uses and so you can use
these things to spit out the patterns
for you wouldn't it be great if at least
that easy code that is boilerplate and
annoying and I just have to retype all
those names all the time would just be
generated for me
I want to leave you with a thought when
we program and we look at someone else's
code it's an it don't take to us what's
going on
oftentimes we just get frustrated like
what was this person thinking this is
just garbage and then we look at the
blame and it's us you know but it is
it's opaque
if if six months ago us wrote some code
we have no idea what it's doing because
it's the series of transformations that
in each of them they might be declared
of but when you combine them together
they're not they're hard to think about
and so I think me enter is a really
important step in this future I think
it's a really important exploration a
journey to try to find a way to have a
more transparent future where when you
go look at code you can tell what it's
doing because it matches the data that
it's transforming and if programming is
just data transformation as I think a
lot of people believe why wouldn't we do
that
why wouldn't we talk about our data
directly so that's that's what I really
want to leave you with not go use me in
there although go go use me and ER but
go make a more transparent future thank
you very much
[Applause]